welcome to Hari saw is the channel where
we discussed the latest tech news and
dove into newest tech products so is the
gtx 1180 actually coming in 2018 but
before we get into that make sure to hit
that subscribe button so that you would
be updated with latest tech news related
to gaming and pcs so starting off there
are so many rumors and leaks that are
suggesting that the gtx 1180 is going to
come in august or in the fall of this
year however recently at Computex jensen
huang who is the CEO of nvidia actually
said that the gtx 1180 series and 1100
series itself is not coming out for a
very long time he specifically said that
the next generation of GPUs from Nvidia
won't launch for a long time from now
but what exactly is a long time well
when I first hear that it makes me think
probably at least 2019 however there
have been so many rumors and leaks about
the gtx 1180 coming this year so what is
actually going to happen so first let's
look at all the rumors and leaks that we
have so far and make a conclusion from
all that probably the biggest thing that
was suggesting that the gtx 1100 series
was going to come out at the end of 2018
was that gamers nexus found out that sk
hynix
was going to start to GDR 6 memory
production during the summer and even
bigger clue is that india themselves
announced that they're going to be
detailing the next generation of GPUs at
the hot chips conference in August so
based on these details
it seems really convincing that the gtx
1180 and the 1100 series are going to
come up before the end of this year but
at the same time if you really think
about it there isn't really a motive for
india to push it out so quickly in the
first place
first of all despite it being 2 years
since the 10th series originally came
out there is still high demand for these
GPUs and many people are even willing to
overpay for them also GPU prices have
just started to hit MSRP and that will
drive a lot more sales and so I doubt in
video want to miss out on those as well
on top of this there's really no
competition either the rx 500 series has
been inflated for over a year now and
the baking series isn't barely able to
compete with the higher level nvidia
graphics cards so as a result there is
no pressure from other companies making
Vidya want to release the next series of
GPUs sooner so there really is no reason
for NVIDIA to rush the next generation
of GPUs also another big concern with
releasing the GPUs or earlier Nvidia is
that GD r6 has the potential of leading
to another huge mining boom while that
would lead to a lot of sales for Nvidia
and they would like that at the same
time I doubt they would want to make
their main target audience of gamers
angry again so if the gtx 1180 and 1100
series is not coming up before the end
of this year what exactly are they
coming out well what a lot of articles
are suggesting is that in the conference
in August and video will simply go over
the architecture specific details and
later on at CES 2019 is when they'll
actually release the cards so pretty
much the launch right at the beginning
of 2019
I doubt in video would drag it on any
longer than that because GDD are six
production is starting really soon and
the conference is in August so it
wouldn't make sense to push it over four
months after the reveal so going back to
the original question is the gtx 1180
actually coming out in 2018 well maybe
not when you really think about it
there's no reason for NVIDIA to launch
it so early and on top of that all the
leaks and rumors that we've heard so far
could just as easily apply if the gtx
1180 and 1100 series were launched the
beginning of 2019
instead the end of 2018 and with the
comment that mr. Wong made I think that
it may be definitely possible for the
media to wait till the beginning of 2019
to release eleven other series instead
of releasing it at the end of 2018 but
there is one thing that I think could
motivate in-video to actually launch it
earlier
I don't think NVIDIA would want to miss
out on the holiday season of 2018
because that would drive a lot of sales
for the new GPUs so that kind of makes
me think that in video we'll launch the
new series and fall but at the same time
the comment that mr. Huang made makes me
think that they're gonna launch it at
the beginning
19 so make sure to comment down below
which one of those you think it's
actually going to happen
so overall the 1100 series is still
definitely coming but maybe a few months
later than what we originally
anticipated based on what mr. Hong has
said however he may have just made that
comment in order to stop current
generation sales from going down so what
do you guys think mr. Hong means when he
says not for a long time does that mean
in the fall or does that mean 2019 make
sure to comment down below what you guys
think because I do read all my comments
and I'm curious as to what you guys
think so make sure to post your thoughts
also if you guys like this video then
make sure to drop a like and hit that
subscribe button if you guys like to see
more videos just like this one but until
next time bye
[Music]